I try not to Google myself because it's
very prideful and I'm usually too busy
staring at myself in the mirror but my
producers have decided to Google me and
figure out what Auto completes when you
type in little prompts pertaining to me
so with great trepidation let's take it
away does Michael nolles have a
wife sorry Ladies sorry and sorry men I
know some of you you're hoping hoping
against hope but no that's not going to
work out for either of you groups I am
married I'm very happily married to
sweet little Alisa does Michael no speak
[Music]
Italian where does Michael nolles
live that was antifa usually looks that
one up that's where they try to find we
need to call security and get that one
scrubbed from Google that's not that's
not a good one to have pop up how much
does Michael nolles make not enough you
know actually on this I think it was a
family member someone turned me on to
the fact that if you look up that
question it will return an answer but
the answer is just based on nothing one
of them said I make relatively little
money I thought what the heck but then
another one said I was worth much much
more money that I'm actually worth
they're just completely random and so
whenever you look at those sites of
public figures and how much do they it's
completely based on nothing fi fugazi
it's a wasi it's a woozy it's a fairy
dust and I of course would like the
number to be much much higher than even
what Google is returning what time does
the Michael nolles show start 8:30
Central baby 8:30 a.m. Central 9:30 a.m.
eastern which is 6:30 a.m. Pacific time
which when I lived in La was very very
brutal what degree does Michael nolles
have a black black belt is what I have I
have a bachelor's degree even though I'm
a married man as the first question
proves I have a bachelor's degree that's
a good one that's it I have no
particularly Advanced degree I don't
have a master's I don't have a PhD I'd
like to get an honorary doctorate so I
can put doctor on all my credit cards
and airplane tickets and business cards
and everything else for me I'm a simple
man merely a Bachelor of
Arts what does Michael noll's wife do
what doesn't she do she cleans she cooks
she raises my children she keeps my home
she has a job but that we that's like we
put that to the side you know she's
she's a she's somehow a full-time
Homemaker and sort of does other she
does everything she does everything with
upam how many languages does Michael N
speak it depends how you count it I
speak English with relative fluency do
you speak American
I speak Italian a little bit of French
enough to get me around a little bit in
France a little bit of Latin just enough
to get me around in Mass cuz I attend
the Latin Mass uh Touch of Esperanto
what which uh it's basically me George
Soros and a bunch of weirdo Libs who
learn you can learn espiranto in like
five lessons and so I I took the online
course or the computer course back when
I was in high school looks like the
Falcon Le Club back from the dead can
the espiro society be far behind I mean
ESO I've forgotten most of it but if I
ever run into George Soros I can I can
converse a little bit with him right now
go to genus cell.com nsyt our friends
over at genell have launched a new
product called genell 3 which works fast
on your under eye bags and puffiness
jell 3
is smooth luxurious and uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration it's like Gatorade for
your skin water sucks Gatorade is better
what this new genu cell technology keeps
your skin looking young and healthy for
years to come the genu cell fall
Classics package also includes a jawline
treatment for a more firm neck and
jawline it also includes genu cell's
anti- wrinkle moisturizer and deep
Firming Serum get your skin ready for
the cold and dry weather if you don't
look and feel your absolute best you
will get your money back no questions
asked go to Jas cell.com
nsyt or you can call 800 skin 211 for
extra discounts on this amazing fall
package get results in 12 hours or less
the immediate effects are included for
free that is J cell.com letter y letter
T or by calling 800 i n skin
211 what watch does Michael nolles wear
uh it depends back in the day I would
wear whatever watch our sponsors gave me
and then we stopped having watch
sponsors so this watch is a Rolex date
just which I got to celebrate the birth
of my baby and the turning in of my
first book with words uh which both
occurred on the same day so I was typing
in the hospital room as my wife was
screaming bloody murder I I said keep it
down I'm trying to finish my book I sent
it in and I said if I don't splurge on a
ice watch for this occasion my first
baby in my first real book I never will
and the fun thing about this watch is I
had a Chinatown knockoff of basically
this exact watch when I was in high
school so got that but I got a million
watches I got cheap watches I got I got
all sorts but this is this is the one
that'll get me robbed in a third world
country or something is Michael noes
married sorry ladies o keeps coming up
to the top hm got Mr Riz over here huh
Don Giovani is Michael Nolls related to
Beyonce not yet not yet I'm thinking
she'll be my second wife and then she
won't even have to change her name it'll
be very simple and then they can't call
me a racist anymore yeah actually they
will they call Candace Owens racist she
herself is black so uh yeah not not yet
is Michael nolles Italian so I thought I
was but then I did a show with Brett
Cooper it was a lie detector thing
Michael was your mother Italian
yes she wasn't so I don't know what was
my mother Tibetan Chinese Nigerian I
don't know is my Michael NS running for
president not yet is Michael nolles wife
I am not wife I am husband Michael
nolles is husband why waste time say lot
word when few word do trick is Michael
nolles an actor I was an actor I'm the
only man I think ever in the history of
the theater who has worked
professionally as an actor theater film
television New York Los Angeles
classically trained who has ever later
on been offered acting roles in and said
no because I no longer want to be an
actor is Michael nolles a doctor I am a
doctor in the in the Deep sense of the
word because you know doctor doesn't
mean physician it means teacher and I
like to teach the libs you know I go
around the country I go around the world
actually and I try to instruct the libs
out of the error of their ways into good
true and beautiful things I don't yet
have the degree I very much would like
an honorary doctorate I've lectured at
dozens of colleges not one of them has
had the good decent
to give me an honorary doctorate but I
very much would like one so if you run
an academic institution please give me
the honorary doctorate so that I can
insist on Ben Shapiro calling me a
doctor wow very funny Michael what is
Michael noll's net worth wouldn't you
like to
know I actually am not even totally sure
I like barely look at my financial
statements I just have my wife look at
it I gave up counting it I mean I had to
it was just so much she could be robbing
me blind probably someone is not robbing
Us blind because she at least is
responsible and looks at it but I just I
don't even look at it I do not when I
come out and I write a book or I do a
show or I own the libs or whatever I am
not doing it primarily for the money the
money is just kind of a nice thing that
comes along with it that's it that's all
anyone wants to know about me can they
marry me do I speak another language how
much money can they get out of me those
are those two are probably related
actually what watch do I wear don't you
want to know how I feel don't you want
to know what I
believe don't you want to know come on
don't you want to know me for
me
huh huh see you next time come on guys
just cut the
[Music]
camera